تبحث الشرطه العراقيه عن طفل ظهر في مقطع
فيديو ليله احتفال براس السنه داخل ملهى
ليلي الطفل كان يمطر الاموال على راقصه
وسط اجواء صاخبه ما اثار ردود فعل غاضبه
المدونين على مواقع التواصل ابدا استغرابه
من السماح لطفل بدخول ملهى ليلي رغم ذلك
يتنافى مع القوانين والقيود التي تفرضها
السلطات العراقيه لذلك دعم مدير الشرطه
المجتمعيه العميد غالب العطيه عبر صفحته
في فيسبوك الى تزويد معلومات عن الطفل حيث
جار البحث عنه
فراس فراس مره
[موسيقى]
سوري
الاموال تفاصيل اوفى ان كانت لديكم منظمه
مسؤوله عن حقوق الطفل هو ماكو غرابه
بالنسبه لنا كراس السعوديين وموثقين
لانتهاكات حقوق الانسان وحقوق الطفوله على
وجه الخصوص او تواجد طفل في ملهى ليلي لكن
هي الكاميرات والثقت هذا الشيف طلع
للاعلام
هذا انتهاك واضح وحقيقي
لحقوق الطفوله بالعراق مع شديد الاسف مثل
هذا الطفل المفروض ينشر لها فيديو بتميز
بدراسه وهو يدرس اللغه الانجليزيه او حل
المساله رياضيه صعبه مثل ما بتعرف عليها
بقيه البلدان لكن للاسف اليوم الطفوله
وحقوق الطفوله على الرغم من ان العراق
بقوانين حقيقيه مختص بالطفوله والعراق
صادق على همم اتفاقيه حقوق الطفل همم
وكذلك على على البروتو كولين الملحقين
الخاص يعني الخاصه بالاطفال اللي هي
الاتجار بالاطفال طبعا هو هو هذا يعني
يمثل جزء او يمثل حاله من حاله الاشجار
بالطفوله وايضا البروتوكول الخاص بمنع
استخدام الاطفال الفترات الحرب نعم طيب
انسان يعني المتابع للفيديو ولا تعابير
وجه طفل يعني يبدو عليه السعاده وكانه مش
مغصوب انه يجيء على هذا المكان بالتالي
يعني مسؤوليه اتمنى اليوم كيف دخل الى هذا
الملح
طبعا هو اكيد باين عليه السعاده لان هو
متربي في بيئه وموجود ضمن بيئه هذه البيئه
اييه يعني متعايشه مع فكره تواجدها
بالنوادي الليليه هو طفل يعني هو غير واعي
غير بالغ هو ما يفتهم هذا المكان خطر هذا
المكان غلط ويحس بالوجود هذا المكان انجاز
حس روحه انه هو كبير اكو تشجيع اكو تصفيه
اكو حاله من السعاده للمحيطين للاجابه
لهذا المكان المسؤوليه الحقيقيه بالدرجه
الاولى هي غياب الرقابه الحكوميه غياب
التعليم الزامي احنا للاسف عندنا التعليم
الزامي فقط ممكن الابتدائيه بالقانون لكن
هو منفذ
بطريقه حقيقيه اساليب التفعيل القوانين
بالعراق للاسف هي اساليب قديمه وغير
موجوده يعني المفروض يكون التعليم الزاميم
من يعني من همم من الابتدائي
واقوى رقابه حكوميه تحاسب الاهل